the coronavirus crisis has taken another
staggering turn for the worse more than
77 thousand new cases were reported
yesterday that beats the old one day
record by nearly 10,000 the daily death
toll it's rising to is more than nine
hundred including a record number 156
that was in Florida meanwhile the
national debate over wearing masks is
intensifying as large parts of the
economy remain at a standstill or lead
national correspondent David beg no is
at the Port of Miami where cruise ships
are staying at the dock for now David
for how much longer
first September 30th Anthony the CDC is
the one that issued a no sale order look
you mentioned the masks I have to tell
you from being here for the last two or
three weeks there's a lot of people
walking around here that are not wearing
masks and in talking to business owners
and political leaders a lot of them are
asking each other the same question are
we gonna go through another shutdown
listen to the mayor of Miami I also want
to stress to them the severity and the
seriousness now we find ourselves in the
mayor of Miami Francis Suarez says he's
meeting with business leaders today to
talk about the possibility of shutting
down again frankly his neighbor to the
east Miami Beach Mayor Dan Gelber says
avoiding another lockdown depends on the
actions of all miami-dade County
residents if people don't wear masks the
decisions gonna be made for all of us
because the trajectory we've been going
on for the last couple weeks is
unsustainable Florida does not have a
statewide mask mandate and there's still
intense resistance to masks look at
these images from a Royal Palm Beach
Walmart the Palm Beach County Sheriff's
Department says this man seen pushing an
elderly man in a wheelchair
pulled a gun on another shopper after a
confrontation that happened over masks
in Utah there was a County meeting about
masks for school children that was
adjourned early because the meeting
itself was in violation of health
guidelines
this is the exact opposite of what we
need to be doing we are supposed to be
physically distancing wearing masks the
governors of Arkansas and Colorado
announced masks mandates of their own
Thursday they're now required in at
least 30 states meanwhile CBS and Target
joined the growing list of companies
moving forward with masks mandates for
all customers what the scientists are
telling us is that the right thing to do
is to wear masks in the city of Atlanta
Marrakesh elaine's bottoms has
essentially told Governor Brian Kemp
bring it on the governor has filed a
lawsuit against her and the City Council
to block the mayor's masks mandate
he says the mayor's order is more
restrictive than his and claims mayor
bottoms has exceeded her authority I am
Not Afraid of the city being sued and
I'll put our policies up against anyone
any day of the week there are at least
15 other cities and counties in the
state of Georgia that implemented their
own mask orders before the governor
overruled them one more thing before we
go southeast of here in Puerto Rico the
governor there has partially rolled back
their reopening after a tenfold increase
in cases if you fly to Puerto Rico now
you've got to show up with a negative
PCR test result and Tony what's
interesting is as of the last few days
the majority of people arriving in
Puerto Rico are coming from Florida an
epicenter of the pandemic yeah it could
be a problem David thank you very much